next callers from the two-five to area
code caller from - five - go ahead
hello David sorry for Sarah a little bit
I'm not feeling great right now
all right go ahead who's it um I was I
was wondering about you were wrong if
you have any opinions about the pirate
party international movement Trebek
Internet party of New Zealand if you had
heard about them I've heard about it I
know nothing about it so I couldn't
really give you an informed opinion are
you are you a member
um I am NOT a member I have worked with
I know some of the members from
internationally I live in the States of
course but um they have some very
interesting on platforms and I thought
it was just somebody very interesting
what's one position of theirs that you
like um one of the bigger ones is of
course in it all especially the see palm
internet party we New Zealand is they're
very anti mass surveillance and trying
to undo a lot of what has occurred
through the five eyes treaty Oh mass I
thought you said they're very anti
masturbation I'm sorry anti mass survey
oh that's my father not yours okay
that's that's interesting so so privacy
is a big thing yeah all right well
listen I will look into it I wish I
could I could say more about it how did
you how did you even become a follower
of this um so when Barrett Brown got out
of prison I know you've covered a story
in the past yep um he started a group
called he's started to work on like a
collaborative framework called the
pursuance project and so through there a
lot of them he's talked about that
they've had people talk about hackathons
and stuff like that and they were
talking about people utilizing their
framework and that's one of the groups
it's been working with Barrett Brown and
their pursuance project is the pirate
parties got and so on from there I kind
of learned a lot more about it
alright I will research and then get
back to you appreciate the question okay
have a great day do all right very good
YouTube twice by the way Pat he refused
to give his name I don't think that
that's a coincidence
okay anonymity is accepted which is
absolutely and completely fine
absolutely